Hi there, it's Marianne here. Before we dive into today's episode, I want to quickly let you know about something exciting that's happening right now. If you've ever wondered how to create income that works for you, rather than constantly trading your time for money, then you'll love the Race to Recurring Revenue Challenge with my business mentor, Lisa Johnson. This challenge is designed to help you build sustainable income streams. And whether you're an aspiring psychologist, a mental health professional, or in a completely different field,
大家好，我是Marianne。在进入今天的话题之前，我想快速向大家介绍一件目前正在进行的激动人心的事情。如果你曾经想过如何创造为你工作的收入，而不是不断地用时间换金钱，那么你一定会喜欢我商业导师Lisa Johnson发起的“经常性收入竞赛”（Race to Recurring Revenue Challenge）。这个挑战旨在帮助你建立可持续的收入来源。无论你是立志成为心理学家、心理健康专业人士，还是来自完全不同的领域，
the principles can work for you. There are also wonderful prizes to be won directly by Lisa herself. And if you join the challenge by my link, you can be in with a chance of winning a one-to-one hours coaching with me, Dr. Marianne Trent. Do you want to know more? Of course you do. Head to my link tree, Dr. Marianne Trent, or check out my social media channels, or send me a quick DM and I'll get you all the details. Right, let's get on with today's episode. If you're looking to become a psychologist, then let this be your guide. episode. With Dr. Marianne Trent Hi, welcome along to the Aspiring Psychologist podcast.
这些原则都同样适用。Lisa本人还会直接提供丰厚的奖品。如果你通过我的链接加入挑战，还有机会赢取与我——Marianne Trent博士一对一的一小时辅导。想了解更多吗？当然想。请前往我的Linktree页面（Dr. Marianne Trent），查看我的社交媒体频道，或者给我发个私信，我会告诉你所有细节。好了，让我们开始今天的节目吧。如果你正寻求成为一名心理学家，那么让这期节目成为你的指南。欢迎收听《有抱负的心理学家播客》（Aspiring Psychologist podcast），我是Marianne Trent博士。
I am Dr. Marianne Trent and I'm a qualified clinical psychologist. Hope that you have had a really lovely Easter break if you are listening to it as this episode drops at 6am on Monday. So today is episode 70 of the podcast, which feels like kind of a big deal. And it means I've stayed really, really consistent, which I'm really pleased about. And I've sent an email to my mailing list every week to tell them about the podcast. So if you're not already on the mailing list and you want to be reminded when new episodes drop, if you're not already subscribing, but even if you are already subscribing, sometimes, you know, life gets in the way and we forget to listen to our favorite podcasts. So yeah, why not sign up to my podcast mailing list, which you can do by going to my website, www.goodthinkingpsychology.co.uk. And then if
我是Marianne Trent博士，一名合格的临床心理学家。如果你是在周一早上6点节目发布时收听的，希望你度过了一个非常愉快的复活节假期。今天是播客的第70期，感觉意义重大。这意味着我一直保持着非常稳定的更新，对此我感到非常高兴。我每周都会给我的邮件列表发送邮件，告知他们播客的更新。所以，如果你还没有加入邮件列表，又想在有新节目发布时收到提醒，或者即使你已经订阅了，但有时生活琐事缠身，我们可能会忘记收听最喜欢的播客。所以，何不注册我的播客邮件列表呢？你可以访问我的网站 www.goodthinkingpsychology.co.uk，然后
you scroll to the bottom of that first page, or that matter, any page on the site, you will see a little thing that says subscribe to mailing list. And if you are listening on Spotify or Apple podcasts, I love it if you would take a moment to rate and review if you're watching me on YouTube hi please do subscribe and like this video as it helps us to reach more of a wider audience so today was originally scheduled to be one of the podcast episodes that I've already recorded but haven't quite finished editing and yeah I've had a week off and always it was my plan to tidy those up but instead I actually did just have a week off because you're allowed to do that um and so yeah I found myself with an episode that wasn't ready and so I thought I'd just create a very short one um to yeah to encourage you to use your time off as time off as well. And to just pay reference to where you might be at right now. Because if you are having interviews for whatever realm of psychology
滚动到首页底部，或者网站上的任何页面，你会看到一个写着“订阅邮件列表”的小栏目。如果你是在Spotify或Apple Podcasts上收听，如果你能花点时间评分和评论，我会非常感激。如果你是在YouTube上观看，嗨，请务必订阅并点赞这个视频，这有助于我们触达更广泛的受众。今天的节目原定是我已经录制好但还没完全剪辑完的一期，但我休了一周假，本来计划在那期间整理好，但实际上我只是好好休息了一周，因为你有权这样做。所以，我发现自己没有准备好节目，于是我想制作一期非常简短的节目，鼓励大家把假期真正当作假期来过，并关注一下你现在的状态。因为如果你正在参加任何心理学领域的面试，
you're going into, I'm aware that there is a bit of hiatus at the moment a bit of a break over the Easter break probably to let the staff who are running the interviews have their Easter time off as well but it means that if you were in the in your stride really with interviews you might now be feeling a bit like what do I do now how do I maintain this you know um there's no energy going on you know now I'm just supposed to sit here and you know look at easter eggs and be cheery and suddenly have time for my family when actually what I want to do is you know submerge myself in um research theory and uh clinical vignettes you know it can be tricky to straddle the two so I'm sending you love if that's what you're finding to be the case um and also um someone made my day the other day um I was just going to bed and I checked my
我知道目前正处于复活节假期的间歇期，可能是为了让负责面试的工作人员也能享受假期。但这意味着，如果你之前面试状态正佳，现在可能会感到有点迷茫：我该怎么办？我该如何保持这种状态？现在好像没什么动力了，我本该坐在这里吃复活节彩蛋，表现得兴高采烈，突然间有了时间陪家人，但实际上我真正想做的是沉浸在研究理论和临床案例中。要在两者之间取得平衡确实很棘手。如果你正面临这种情况，我为你送上关怀。另外，前几天有人让我的一天变得很美好，当时我正准备睡觉，检查了一下我的
LinkedIn because I'm very badly behaved like that and I saw that someone had sent me a lovely message I wanted to share that with you so there there's an intro, but I won't read that bit, but I'll cut to the chase. I wanted you to know that I'm a big fan of your podcast, not just the jingles, but the content as well. My colleagues introduced me to it and I've been listening ever since. I'm really interested to know how psychologists conduct themselves when in the therapy room, whatever that means these days. I'm particularly interested in reflexivity and I've gained a lot by listening to how you talk to your clients, the sort of questions you ask, the things you might pick up on and how you generally carry yourself. I suppose in that sense you're sort of role model
LinkedIn，因为我有时候真的很不乖，我看到有人给我发了一条可爱的消息，我想和大家分享一下。我就不读开头了，直接说重点。我想让你知道我是你播客的忠实粉丝，不仅喜欢片头曲，也喜欢内容。我的同事向我推荐了它，从那以后我就一直在听。我非常想知道心理学家在治疗室里是如何表现的，无论这在今天意味着什么。我对反思性（reflexivity）特别感兴趣，通过听你如何与客户交谈、你提出的问题、你注意到的事情以及你通常的表现方式，我获益良多。我想在某种意义上，你就是我的榜样，
to me. I wanted to reach out and tell you that you've helped me in my journey, as I've today found out that I've been offered a place on the counselling doctorate at UWE, starting this September. So thank you for doing what you do. It's genuinely been a massive help. I even mentioned you on my personal statement as someone I model myself on, whilst also bringing my authentic self to. Thanks so much for being such a positive influence. Super grateful. Wishing you all the best. Honestly, when I read that, it almost brought me to tears because the idea that what I'm doing is making a difference is incredible.
我想联系你并告诉你，你帮助了我走过这段旅程。我今天得知我被西英格兰大学（UWE）的心理咨询博士项目录取了，今年九月开学。所以谢谢你所做的一切，这真的非常有帮助。我甚至在个人陈述中提到了你，说你是我效仿的对象，同时我也在展现真实的自我。非常感谢你成为如此积极的影响力。超级感激，祝你一切顺利。老实说，当我读到这些时，我几乎热泪盈眶，因为想到我所做的事情正在产生影响，这真是太不可思议了。
Honestly, when I read that, that just made my day. You know, I created this podcast because I wanted to be able to level the playing field, to be able to give people access to thoughts, insights, reflections of a qualified psychologist, if you are not in that position where you have ready access to one or if you are but would welcome alternate perspectives or maybe you don't even like the person that's supervising you or those around you in your team and yeah I wanted to be able to have you guys advance your skills theory practice practice reflections and knowledge um you know but not be held up by those that you find yourself around you know because we're all busy people we absolutely are not everyone has got the time to spend with aspiring psychologists um you know ideally it would all be job planned and it would be happening regularly but even with the best of will in the world, that's not always the case. So that's part of the reason why I put this podcast together and why I'm remaining consistent with that. So I'm thrilled, you know, when people contact me just to say how valued it is, really.
老实说，读到这些让我的一天都变得美好。你知道，我创建这个播客是因为我想拉平竞争环境，让人们能够接触到一位合格心理学家的想法、见解和反思。如果你没有现成的渠道接触到心理学家，或者即使有，但想听听不同的观点，又或者你不喜欢你的督导或团队中的其他人，我希望你们能够提升自己的技能、理论、实践反思和知识，而不被周围的人所阻碍。因为我们都是忙碌的人，并不是每个人都有时间陪伴有抱负的心理学家。理想情况下，这应该被纳入工作计划并定期进行，但即使有最好的意愿，情况也并非总是如此。这就是我制作这个播客并保持更新的部分原因。所以，当人们联系我表达他们的感激之情时，我真的感到非常激动。
And that's why reviews mean a great deal as well. So, yeah, if you do have a moment to drop me a review or if you'd like to leave me an audio testimonial for the podcast about the podcast itself or about the books the clinical psychologist collective or the aspiring psychologist collective or the grief collective for that matter you can do so very easily very simply by going to my website, www.goodthinkingpsychology.co.uk forward slash podcast. And there's very quick click button on there that will take you to the platform that I use for recording testimonials. So honestly, that is about it for me for today. I hope you've, yeah, you can give me permission to give you a short episode today because everybody, even those working in mental health, especially those working in mental health, deserve and need time off.
这就是为什么评论也非常重要。所以，如果你有时间给我写条评论，或者想为播客本身、或者关于《临床心理学家集体》（The Clinical Psychologist Collective）、《有抱负的心理学家集体》（The Aspiring Psychologist Collective）或《悲伤集体》（The Grief Collective）这些书留下音频感言，你可以非常轻松地通过我的网站 www.goodthinkingpsychology.co.uk/podcast 来完成。上面有一个非常快捷的点击按钮，会带你进入我录制感言的平台。老实说，今天就到这里了。希望你能允许我今天制作一期简短的节目，因为每个人，即使是从事心理健康工作的人，尤其是从事心理健康工作的人，都值得也需要休息。
Very likely you too. So you can give yourself permission to not work on the days where you're not working. You can give yourself permission to only work within the hours where you are working and where you're paid to work. If there's a culture whereby you work extra, it's okay to actually question and challenge that culture. It's okay to leave at your agreed finish time and only start at your agreed start time it's absolutely okay um and you know it's okay to be flexy as well if you need to be um discuss that with your management team and your supervisor if you need that at any given point you're not necessarily saying you need it forever
你很可能也一样。所以你可以允许自己在不工作的日子里不工作。你可以允许自己在工作时间内工作，并且只在获得报酬的时间内工作。如果存在一种需要额外加班的文化，质疑并挑战这种文化是没问题的。在约定的下班时间离开，在约定的上班时间开始，这完全没问题。如果你需要的话，保持灵活也是可以的，如果需要的话，在任何时候与你的管理团队和督导讨论这个问题。你并不一定非要永远保持这种状态，
but you might be saying you need it right now and you know you're a human and we don't want you to burn out. And so time off and working in a way that helps you maintain your best for yourself and your clients is really important. So don't be afraid to ask those questions about whether there's any way that things could be done differently while still doing your job. The answer might be no. There might be good logistical managerial reasons for that. But it's OK to ask those questions.'t even help myself there could I have said I was going and then I chucked in a little learning point but do remember that we've got more compassionate Q&A dates coming up and next one is on Monday the 17th of April 2023 at 7 30 p.m and the one after that is on Tuesday the 2nd of May at 7.30pm and they'll be live streamed across my socials. So yeah if you've got any questions in advance let me know otherwise do tune in live and feel free to ask any questions there or just give me a high and a high five
但你可能现在需要它。你是人类，我们不希望你精疲力竭。所以，休息以及以一种有助于你为自己和客户保持最佳状态的方式工作是非常重要的。因此，不要害怕询问是否可以在完成工作的同时以不同的方式做事。答案可能是“不”，这可能有合理的后勤或管理原因，但提出这些问题是可以的。我甚至没忍住，本来打算结束了，结果又加了一个小知识点。但请记住，我们还有更多的“同情心问答”（compassionate Q&A）日期即将到来，下一次是在2023年4月17日周一晚上7:30，再下一次是在5月2日周二晚上7:30，它们将在我的社交媒体上直播。所以，如果你有任何问题，请提前告诉我，否则欢迎准时收看直播，随时提问，或者只是跟我打个招呼、击个掌，
that's fine too. The replay for the first one is also available via my YouTube, Dr. Marianne Trent. People are finding the Clinical Psychologist Collective and the Aspiring Psychologist Collective really useful reads as they prepare for interviews. So you might well find that useful, too. Hope, as I said, you've had a lovely Easter and I will look forward to catching up with you very soon from Monday at 6am for the next episode of the Aspiring Psychologist podcast. Until then, thanks for being part of my world and do stay kind to yourselves. Take care. health professionals on their way to getting qualified. So many tips and lessons to learn from. So many things that you can try. The Aspiring Psychologist Collective.
那也很好。第一期的回放也可以通过我的YouTube频道（Dr. Marianne Trent）观看。人们发现《临床心理学家集体》和《有抱负的心理学家集体》在准备面试时非常有用，所以你可能也会觉得它们很有帮助。正如我所说，希望你度过了一个愉快的复活节，我期待着很快与你再次相聚，下周一早上6点，收听下一期《有抱负的心理学家播客》。在那之前，感谢你成为我世界的一部分，请善待自己。保重。为成为合格专业人士的心理健康从业者们。有很多技巧和经验可以学习，有很多事情你可以尝试。《有抱负的心理学家集体》。
The Aspiring Psychologist Collective guys with this podcast that you'll find you'll be on your way to being qualified it's the aspiring psychologist podcast with dr marianne My name's Jana and I'm a trainee psychological well-being practitioner. I read the Clinical Psychologist Collective book. I found it really interesting about all the different stories and how people got to become a clinical psychologist it just amazed me how many different routes there are to get there and there's no perfect way to become one and this kind of filled me of confidence that no I'm not doing it wrong and put less pressure on myself so if you're feeling a bit uneasy about becoming a clinical psychologist I definitely recommend this just to put yourself at ease and everything will be okay. But trust me, you will not put the book down once you start. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
《有抱负的心理学家集体》，伙计们，通过这个播客，你会发现自己正在通往合格心理学家的道路上。这是《有抱负的心理学家播客》，我是Marianne博士。我叫Jana，是一名心理健康实习从业者。我读了《临床心理学家集体》这本书。我发现关于所有不同的故事以及人们如何成为临床心理学家的经历非常有趣。我惊讶于有这么多不同的途径可以达到目标，没有成为心理学家的完美方式，这让我充满了信心，不再觉得我做错了，也减轻了我的压力。所以，如果你对成为临床心理学家感到有点不安，我绝对推荐这本书，它能让你安心，一切都会好起来的。相信我，一旦开始读，你就停不下来。本期节目暂无评论。点击转录中的任何句子即可发表评论。